I've always been very passionate so you
know I'm an optimist about how
technology can make a difference and so
I focus on that and that way you can
tend to forget about the other things
the the rest is noise
we believe that software is at a stage
where you know software increasingly is
playing a more and more critical role in
solving things which it didn't before
okay so to me when I look at cars
people's kind an inordinate amount of
time in cars these are resources which
are very poorly utilized right now as we
speak
you know you can look outside and you
can see all the cars which are private
cars right we ready to get here is just
sitting in the parking structure so they
can't use less than ten percent so we
see these problems and we see okay can
we solve that scale and that's computing
play a part in it software and computer
science and while the effort may seem
ambitious or crazy you know we take a
very disciplined approach inside right
you know so those are taught through
like businesses which we are building
and it's just to be able to take a long
term view but we run them in a very
disciplined way our research can be
longer-term we never know whether some
of them even makes viable business
applications but we want to push the
technology at times because you don't
know what's possible on the other side
you just watch - amazing clips with
sundar Pichai take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]